alright guys so yes I have reviewed
Dragonball Evolution before and some of
you may know that it is my least
favorite movie of all time so why am i
reviewing it again it's kind of the
first review that got me noticed it's
the first big review where I noticed
that I woke up and was like wow I have
over a thousand views on that review
that's awesome and I have new viewers
now and often I get asked what my least
favorite movie of all time is and I'm
gonna talk to you about this in depth so
prepare yourself please
here we go as you guys know I'm a big
fan of Dragon Ball Z I grew up with the
show it meant a lot to me it was part of
my childhood it was such a great thing
to run home from school and a/c Toonami
and experience Dragonball Z as a
teenager it was just one of the greatest
times in my life so when this movie came
along I was of course skeptical anime to
live-action transition in America Justin
Chatwin what in the world is going on
that maker filed us nation what what is
this please don't be what I think it is
and boy was it so the movie opens up and
you get this monologue with these images
of space describing some story that has
absolutely nothing to do with the
original manga in which all the Dragon
Balls must be collected before the
eclipse of the Blood Moon or piccolo
will destroy the earth or some horrible
thing within one minute of this movie I
knew it was awful I felt like Chris
Farley in Billy Madison when he plays
the bus driver then we cut the Justin
Chatwin training with his grandpa go on
while they stand on two like wires now
yes this has a basis in anime you can
imagine that an anime at some point some
people would do that and you would kind
of buy it but when you put this in a
live-action movie and you got Justin
Chatwin and you have some of the worst
green screen I have ever seen it is like
the dumbest opening ever it is the
stupidest opening for the character of
Goku the way Dragon Paul opens go who's
a little boy he has no idea what
anything is yet he goes to high school
and has a crush on chichi and the anime
he doesn't even know what girls are when
he first meets boma
he asks boma where's her tail is because
he assumes everyone has a tail he has no
idea what
email is yet in this film he's like a
reclusive Punk at school who has a crush
on the girl it's just so bad and then he
actually walks up to his grandpa he's
like grandpa I know you've taught me how
to fight but teach me how to get the
girl what am i watching what is this
it's just not Dragon Ball Z at all you
got this crazy line where is like I hate
those kids at school I could take them
apart with one hand then we cut to go
who actually at school and we see that
he's wearing an orange and blue jacket
which is pretty much the closest thing
to being faithful to anything in
Dragonball that this movie does he has a
jacket on that are the same colors and
as Goku's outfit then we meet the jocks
at school who like beat up on Goku they
actually run over Goku's bike well Goku
is on it and almost killed him at school
and now Goku wants to beat him up
because you know he can't he's Goku and
the guys like threatening I was like
punch me right here punch me right here
and we see Justin Chatwin in it this is
what he looks like it's like in the
anime Goku is like a pacifist he knows
how to fight to protect himself in the
people he loves he never has like the
desire to beat up on people it's so bad
and then we get an imaginary daydream
sequence where Goku actually imagines
chichi and slow-motion eating a piece of
fruit with flowers in the background and
we get like these shots of Goku like
seeing the original manga GG likes Goku
so much Goku has no idea about that kind
of relationship
chichi actually forces Goku into
marriage without even telling him what
it is and goes like oh sure whatever
it's fine it's so not like the manga it
is insulting
so chichi invites Goku to her party that
night goku goes there runs into the same
punks again it gets in a fight the fight
is of course filmed and choreographed
awfully half of it looks like a stunt
double I mean you see the guy doing
flips and all they show is from like his
waist down to his feet you don't even
see like Justin Chatwin space once again
these high schoolers are coming at goku
with long metal rods in front of the
entire school basically who are at this
huge party they're actually trying to
like kill goku again they try to run him
over earlier now they're trying to beat
him with rods so in a quick display of
actual story and care
that of course makes no sense Goku
actually tells chichi that he doesn't
know what happened to his parents but
his grandpa Gohan promised to tell him
when he's 18 and guess what today is my
birthday so I'm 18
how does Chi Chi react cool ha ha you
never actually hear what happen to his
parents they just had a random little
scene where a girl who says that never
once later does that situation Ark at
all it's just mentioned briefly then he
goes home finds Gohan is dying because
piccolo crushed his house
piccolo James Marsters or whatever his
name is probably the closest thing to
something that was good in this movie to
be honest on really that's all I can
really think of been Gohan dies in like
the worst display of acting ever from
Justin Chatwin he's like bending over
he's like so sad about and he's just
like crying in his chest insisted so
laughable then we meet Balma played by
emmy rossum she comes up in every line
that this woman says his audio dubbed I
swear and she's after the Dragon Balls
too sure she comes since she has her
capsule which is from the manga she
throws it it turns into a bike like a
transformer
and what does Goku say he goes cool
apparently the writers in this movie
have no idea how to end a scene without
someone's going ahead cool man that's
cool no cut okay good now we can move on
so go bone mama run into Master Roshi
now played by Shyam fat and we have
another fake CG enhanced fight that
looks so unrealistic filled with cheesy
one-liners they're just awful
things like now I'm going to end it and
after this fight is over we have what is
in my opinion the worst line reading I
have ever heard it's impossible for me
to imitate it or explain how bad it is
without just showing it to you he was
murdered I will avenge him but before he
he died he asked me to find you and to
tell you that piccolo has returned I
just want to be there on set the day
where the director goes cut prints good
job Justin moving on and like just walk
up to him and slap him in the face so
now let me cheat a tournament Goku finds
out she's a fighter and gets even more
attracted to her and now they're all
like making eyes at each other and it's
just wonderful eventually like it's
down in this cavern then and Yamcha is
there all of a sudden he shows up and
he's like hey guys what's up
Yamcha has the worst audio dubbed fake
voice I have ever seen he honestly
sounds like a combination of George
Takei and Arnold Schwarzenegger combined
you would think that would be awesome
not in Dragonball Evolution hey guys my
name is yogge ja I can get you out of
that hole of your wife I got this giant
gun in the back that can bore a hole
right through there Oh your name's boba
you could pretty attractive
oh I'm Yamcha then Master Roshi tells a
story using the fire around the campfire
he actually takes his hands and makes
shapes out of the fire that tell a story
and it's just so beautiful isn't it the
manga either we hear more about this
blood moon eclipse thing that's supposed
to happen that he had to collect the
Dragon Balls for that happen so the
world's gonna die and piccolo is gonna
tell her take everything it just makes
no sense at all so you nacho comes down
the hole he's got this giant gun it's
gonna bore through the wall and he takes
his gun he goes everything happens for a
reason bro got that one from daytime TV
just why now suddenly they're attacked
by some random aliens sent by piccolo
that of course had nothing to do with
the manga and there at this lava pit all
of a sudden where the Dragon Ball
apparently is there's a lava there and
whatever so gogo starts to slice all
these aliens in half throw them across
the lava to create a bridge so that he
can hop across that lava to get the
Dragon Ball now keep in mind that we are
still in this realistic world this film
is set up now these please chop it up
these aliens you throwing them across
the thing he's creating a bridge so we
could hop on these aliens these aliens
no they're not melting into the lab and
now they're just kind of floating there
there's they're just floating there as
the lava consumes their bodies you know
that's just how that's what happens when
you throw things in lava right no they
don't get burned up think it's kind of
float there that's what happens god now
ro she meets this new guy they're not
even gonna get into he just meets some
guy that knows all about piccolo and
stuff and talks with him and then he
just goes eh all of a sudden he teaches
Goku the Kamehameha way and he's like
doing this thing where he's like he's
like going like this with his hands that
has nothing to do with how he creates
the Kamehameha wave which is going like
this putting it behind your back saying
the words and
unleashing you don't do some thing where
you're doing like a pop-and-lock move
what is going on
and of course Goku can't quite figure
out the kamehameha yet because you know
he's not ready he's not ready to figure
out the command man he just can't get it
so chichi comes over and like talk to
them and kind of like just goes like hey
Goku it's up oh the son Goku can get the
Kamehameha way be he can actually kind
of warm the energy again because T she
gave him a boner it's like what is going
on chichi just helps I'm gonna just now
some people's henchmen come and there's
a fight in chichi all of a sudden as a
twin and they're fighting and Goku can't
figure out which chichi is which so he
actually goes and attacks the other
chichi and it's not the real TT of
course and that chichi kills Goku and
she escapes now look in the manga and in
this film
Goku references the ability to be able
to sense where his grandpa is and where
Master Roshi is that means that he
should be able to sense which chichi is
which to not have to walk up to some
random chichi and get shot and die but
that's okay though because Master Roshi
resurrects Doku with the Kamehameha wave
that's right
Master Roshi shoots a Kamehameha wave at
Goku's chest and resurrects him that is
clearly in the original manga all right
so I'm gonna skip a few things to the
end of this boom
where go qu suddenly looks at the Blood
Moon it becomes a giant ape now anyone
who doesn't understand what that is from
the manga would just be looking at that
with utter like amazement and white now
even me watching this movie Goku doesn't
look at a Blood Moon and turn to a tape
he just looks at the moon and turns into
an ape he has a tail in the manga it
makes sense you realize that he was a
saying in this film he is a human he's
referenced as a human piccolo even calls
him a human he sees like human powers
failed before and now it will fail again
that means go who's a human there's no
reason he should turn into an ape
none at all he doesn't have a tail he's
a human he's not as saying like he was
in the comics and Master Roshi's look
you must wait just you must fight you
can't be a name so suddenly Goku decides
to turn back into a human because he
suddenly finds the will to be a human
again I guess and we get the dig no but
he's gonna do the Kamehameha he's gonna
do it pick those right there he's gonna
do it and what does he say does he say
it powerfully and awesome like the Goku
that we know from the anime no no he
doesn't
he's freaking out in a teenage giant
burst of angst and goes he's like me
like I can't even I can't even do it
we need Shawn Chimel listen to this is
command man don't even try to do just
stop acting Justin Chatwin stop acting
so Piccolo's defeated blah blah blah
they they stop the thing before the
Eclipse which OS he goes back and he
finds chichi and they make out so what's
the message of this movie save the world
get the girl
make out yeah that's Dragonball for you
that's Dragonball so what's the oneplus
about this movie without credits it's 76
minutes that means you won't be tortured
for too long however I am going to be
torturing the DVD of Dragonball
Evolution that's right I'm actually
gonna go and purchase the Dragonball
Evolution DVD from a used electronics
store so I don't give the company any
money and I'm going to torture that
thing on video very soon in fact look
forward to that man do I hate Dragonball
Evolution worst movie ever if you like
this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck man eyes
[Music]